he's accused of terrible crimes during
kosovo's war for independence from
serbia in the late 1990s but as he
became the first to stand trial in this
special tribunal in the netherlands
saleh mustafa rejected the charges
telling the judge i'm not guilty of the
counts brought here before me by this
gestapo office
in april 1999 mustafa was a commander in
the rebel kosovo liberation army the kla
the prosecution says he was responsible
for the torture of at least six people
and the murder of one person at a
detention compound
it says the victims were accused by
kosovo's ethnic albanian rebels of
collaborating with serbs or not
supporting the kla
these people
they were not enemies of the state of
kosovo
they were not spies
they were fellow community members
innocent
kosovar albanians whose only crime was
to be viewed
for one reason or another as an
impediment to the kla in certain of its
leaders
the kosovo war is believed to have
killed more than 13 000 people it ended
in 1999 after the nato alliance carried
out 11 weeks of airstrikes against
serbian forces
a former deputy prime minister and five
top former serbian military and police
officials were found guilty of war
crimes committed during the conflict
that was at the un tribunal for the
former yugoslavia
but on wednesday the prosecutors said
the saleh mustafa hearing was a
milestone for this court which has taken
six years to bring anyone to trial this
was one of the failings of the
international criminal tribunal
for former yugoslavia not to be able to
really sentence any uh kosovo liberation
army uh soldiers and commanders where it
was clear that some war crimes had been
committed not to the same scale and
intensity as those by the serbian army
that is quite clear but they had also
committed war crimes the new court's
activities are highly sensitive in
kosovo where former rebel commanders
still dominate political life
in june 2020 then president hashim
thatchy was indicted for his alleged
role in nearly a hundred murders while
he led the kla he's currently being held
in the hague awaiting trial nadim baba
al-jazeera